bonsoir à tous et bonne année bienvenue
dans le 7-8 sport l'émission consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
tout de suite le sommaire de votre
magazine vendée globe 2016 le versailles
et éric bellion et laurent polito louis
burton sont dans le top 10 de la course
les deux navigateurs sont proches du cap
horn nous reviendrons sur le périple des
sportifs dans ce magazine
athlétisme pendant les vacances une
vingtaine de jeunes de l'union
athlétique de versailles ont bravé les
températures hivernales pour s'entraîner
en vue des compétitions du mois de
janvier
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
pendant un entraînement au stade bronze
depuis l'équipe senior de plaisir est
actuellement en tête du classement de
fédérale 3 à mi championnat pour
débriefer ce très bon début de saison
nous recevrons dans quelques instants le
coach des plaisirs wa genlis
on prend à présent le large pour parler
du vendée globe
on débute donc par le vendée globe 2000
une loi sont encore en course pour cette
huitième édition le versailles et éric
bellion et laurent bolitar louis burton
sont en direction du mythique cap horn
après 56 jours de compétition ils sont
respectivement 7e et à la dixième classe
retour sur leurs performances pendant
les fêtes le montage est signée à xavier
jana
et le réveillon
avant de commencer
pas de répit pour les skippers evil mois
du vendée globe pendant les fêtes de
noël éric bellion et louis burton ont dû
affronter des vagues de plusieurs mètres
loin de leurs proches
le navigateur de l'imoca comme un seul
homme a réussi à passer l'australie et
se positionne à la 10e place du
classement
faisons gaffe c'est cool merci des liens
bonbons dans le jour de noël le hasard a
voulu qu'eric bellion pas cette journée
aux côtés des skippers en dao coenen et
à l'amour après 50 jours de course c'est
le plus beau noël de ma vie quoi d'avoir
ces trois bateaux 3 imoca du vendée
globe tout près là c'est extraordinaire
de son côté louis burton remonte laurent
bullet un désormais 7e de la course
suite à l'abandon de thomas ruyant
je suis très content même si là en ce
moment c'est un petit peu calme de la
position du bureau vallée et je j'espère
arriver au cap horn dans trois jours
après le cap horn il restera un peu plus
d'un mois en mer l'occasion de
grappiller encore quelques places au
classement
on continue à parler du vendée globe
pour participer à ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale les skippers
ont besoin de sponsors et de mécènes
afin de financer leur bateau et le
matériel qui va avec nous avons pu
rencontrer les financeurs du projet
comme un seul homme du navigateur éric
bellion le montage est signée à exagérer
le versailles et éric bellion est l'un
des novices sur ce vendée globe 2016 le
skipper est en mer depuis cinquante six
jours bien fait en légèreté
surtout continuer à naviguer en étant
prudent mais hélas le bateau quitte ou
bien c'est les bonnes conditions ah oui
c'est chouette hein pour participer à
son premier tour du monde en solitaire
et sans escale éric bellion a eu besoin
de mécènes pour financer un bateau à
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
et l'équipement dernière génération
installé à bord ces derniers se
réunissent tous les quinze jours à paris
pour débriefer l'avancée du navigateur
eric il est venu par 14 mai salle ils
permettent un projet de vivre
et
en fait la différence entre le mécénat
et sponsoring c'est que mes bessette
beaucoup ils n'ont pas leurs noms sur le
bateau
ole isolons mais dans une moindre mesure
est en fait ils ont ils sont fédérés
autour d'eric et autour des valeurs que
porte erika parmi ces quatorze sponsors
on retrouve la société celle force
leader mondial des outils de relation
client l'entreprise investit près de
900000 euros sur trois ans pour
accompagner le navigateur dans son
périple à tous ces éléments et sociale
d'abord l'homme eric et son parcours et
sa façon de raconter ses histoires la
sincérité qu'il dégage et ensuite à
titre égal j'aurais tendance à dire les
valeurs et les valeurs de son projet
quand la raison le coeur se rejoignent
et bien c'est arrivé ensuite il a fallu
en interne que que je combats quelques
quelques idées reçues
parce que tout le monde était d'accord
avec moi mais personne ne voulait me
donner l'argent toujours pareil
à la fin j'ai réussi à trouver l'argent
et on a mis tout le monde d'accord
au plus grand bonheur d'eric millions
qui espère désormais terminé son tour du
monde en solitaire d'ici le mois de
février
amo d'athétisme à présent pendant les
fêtes de noël les enfants profitent
généralement des vacances pour rester au
chaud entre amis ou se reposer avant la
reprise des cours mais certains
continuent de faire du sport à haut
niveau c'est le cas par exemple du club
d'athlétisme de versailles qui proposait
un stage durant les fêtes pour ses
cadets objectif être prêt pour les
compétitions du mois de janvier
un reportage de nicolas à kirill à 8 ce
la biture cet exercice le travail le
pied on cherche à rebondir sur l'avant
du pied on pose pas le talon rebondir se
préparer comme d'habitude même pendant
les fêtes de noël et alors que les
températures avoisinent les 0° ce
mercredi matin 28 décembre ils sont une
vingtaine de jeunes de l'union
athlétique de versailles a bravé le
froid
au programme de la séance des exercices
de mise en jambes et des courses
fractionnées on en profite pour pour
s'entraîner on va presque dire deux fois
plus en quantité en intensité
pourquoi parce que à côté ils n'ont pas
école donc il ya moins de fatigue
avec les devoirs le stress des contrôles
des examens donc ils peuvent un peu plus
se reposer ce qu'on se concentrer
uniquement finalement sur sur l'arc
athlétisme sur leurs entraînements du
lundi au vendredi de 10h à 12h30 ce
stage de fin d'année a pour but de
préparer les futures échéances avec des
compétitions dès le mois de janvier
si vous coupez les deux semaines pendant
les vacances ou même une semaine le
temps que vous coupez c'est le temps qui
sera nécessaire à la rentrée pour se
remettre en route
sauf qu'aujourd'hui si vous coupez deux
semaines sachant que l'échéance
importante à la rentrée elle est dès la
première semaine
vous savez déjà que vous pouvez pas être
compétitif pour être performant sur ce
sur ce cross
alors que la plupart de leurs amis sont
sous la couette lorsqu'il commence
l'entraînement ces jeunes âgés de 14 à
17 ans restent fixés sur leurs objectifs
au début c'est un peu compliqué quand on
reprend un stage donc il en existe un
peu compliqué mais maintenant je me dis
que si je fais ça c'est pour comme ça
j'ai un but c'est de faire un podium
sinon ce serait compliqué aussi tenir
comme il fait froid c'est un peu
compliqué parfois c'est une violence
aussi après il ya les restants il paye
pas et on est on est pas content et on
sait maintenant que travailler pour la
suite
le premier rendez vous de la saison pour
l'union athlétique de versailles est
prévue le 8 janvier à sartrouville deux
semaines plus tard la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines sera le cadre
d'accueil du championnat de france unss
de la course à pied on passe au rugby
l'équipe senior de plaisir est
actuellement en tête de fédérale 3 après
neuf journées de compétition avant les
fêtes ils ont notamment battu le leader
invaincu à ris orangis pour nous parler
de cette dynamique positive nous
recevons l'entraîneur de l'équipe jean
lissague bonsoir jean bonsoir michael
alors avant de parler de cette superbe
série de victoires on va revenir sur le
début de saison de l'équipe qui n'a pas
été simple pour pas si simple en tout
cas il ya eu cette victoire d'un point
contre evreux il y a eu cette défaite
contre mot 10 à 0 c'était le début de
saison que vous attendiez un début de
saison compliqué bon début de saison
compliqué pas par rapport aux résultats
mais par rapport au nombre de blessés
que j'ai enregistrées tout au lond de
ses matches
début de saison où on a fait un début de
saison on a enregistré pas moins de deux
blessés par match et heureusement que on
a eu on a un réservoir assez conséquent
à plaisir pour nous permettre
aujourd'hui à la trêve d'être premier de
poule
et puis il ya eu cette superbe série de
quatre victoires consécutives
là aussi c'était attendu d'enchaîner
autant autant dictaure que consécutives
dont on ne peut pas ne pas s'attendre à
est chez victoire c'est pas possible il
ya eu peut-être un déclic après mot
cette défaite 10 à 0 c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que le score reflète pas le
match
amos est vrai qu on aurait pu au moins
sur ce match-là repartir de mots avec un
point qu'un point de bonus défensif
je pense même si on fait un mauvais
match alors qu'on domine
territorialement mais on voit là on n'a
pas mis les ingrédients nécessaires pour
pour gagner ce match ce jour-là mais
c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu repartir avec
un point
est-ce que ça a été un déclic peut
certainement parce qu'il ya des défaites
qui valent certaines victoires en tous
les cas ça nous a plu bien laisser les
pieds sur terre et ça nous a permis de
bien se reconcentrer pour cette fête de
première partie de saison avec la
projets à venir l'apothéose plutôt le
match contre rhys le dernier match de
championnat où là ça nous a bien souri
justement ce match contre ret surgissent
qui nous avait battus deux fois la
saison dernière
finalement comme vous disiez c'était
l'apothéose c'était peut-être le match
référence que vous attendez depuis que
vous êtes arrivé en poste en septembre
ben c'est un machin ferraille affectueux
rome parce que c'est vrai que rice
on avait perdu 2,2 fois l'année dernière
de peu à chaque fois de très peu à
chaque fois par rapport au contenu des
matches on savait que c'était forcément
deux équipes qui se valent et maintenant
on a eu de la réussite qu'on veut on
peut en avoir l'âme dernier lorsqu'ils
sont venus nous battre à la maison à la
dernière minute
donc là cette année c'est nous qui
n'avons vu et on appris en plus ce bonus
offensif mais bon ça fait partie du jeu
alors vous êtes premiers du championnat
championnat à la mi saison
ou pensez vous pouvez finir premier la
poule l'objectif c'est effectivement de
finir premiers voire deuxième parce que
ces deux premières places bon nous
exempté de premier tour de barrages en
matches aller retour donc deux matches
de moins et l'objectif du club est temps
de monter en fédérale 2 ça nous fait
deux matches de moins et certaines
diront baisse a manqué un petit peu de
compétition si vous enlevez de match
mais moi je peux vous dire qu'en tant
qu'entraîneur ça fait deux matches de
moins et quand yves catonne c'est qu'il
faut il faut il faut passer quatre
matches pour monde et gagner quatre
matchs pour monter ben je préfère en
avoir deux de moins et finir dans les
deux premiers
dernière question jean la réussite
actuelle du club et tient à vos joueurs
où elle tient de vous de vous et de
votre dieu vous formez avec avec
frédéric jardin alors surtout pas cesser
c'est un tout on va dire et je mettrais
même le club en plus que le tout tout
tout tout ce qui peut y avoir autour du
club
c'est pas simplement les joueurs les
joueurs ce sont les des acteurs tous les
matches qu'ils baissent et eux qui
détiennent les clés cce qui vont qui
vont mettre qui vont arriver à mettre en
place
affaire avait à faire ce que nous on
essaie de mettre en place à dakar
trainer il ya aussi tout ce qu'il ya
autour
et tout le club le club le plaisir est
un club très bien structuré avec des
dirigeants à leur place chacun est à sa
place dans ce club et il mérite vraiment
honnêtement de monter en général 2 mais
c'est tout un collectif et c'est tout un
club qui doit monter c'est pas
simplement les joueurs les entraîneurs
c'est vraiment tout le globe
merci à vous gens me c'est bon courage
pour la suite de la saison prochain
match le dimanche 15 janvier à domicile
contre viry châtillon on termine ce
magazine par du handball féminin
l'équipe senior de montilly bretenoux va
mieux après un début de saison compliqué
avec une seule victoire sur les 6
premiers matches lésigny montaigne
viennent d'enchaîner trois victoires de
suite dans le championnat de nationale 2
une série qui leur permet de recoller au
classement les occupe désormais la
neuvième place et vise le top 6 d'ici la
fin de la saison
on écoute le pivot de l'équipe pauline
dit qu on a changé de coach donc ça se
passait bien mais on a aussi des
nouvelles joueuses et il fallait que
tout ensemble on se met d'accord sur le
projet dieu qu'on joue tout ensemble et
et qu'on évite de jouer individuellement
et qu'on monte aussi de plus en plus les
balles donc c'est ce qu'on fait et ça
marche bien donc j'espère que pour 2017
ça continuera c'est la fin de 7,8 sport
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive et très belle année sur tv fil
[Musique]